hey guys how's it going so welcome to my
first ever virtual reality video I'm so
excited because this is going to be so
much fun we had an amazing time shooting
this and I hope that you guys enjoy it
as much as I have enjoyed shooting it so
the best experience is to use your
mobile phone you can look around you can
see everything that I'm seeing and you
can also use your browser this is some
amazing new technology and I cannot wait
for you guys to see the future
well actually the futures here now so
enjoy one of people's biggest fears is
change whether it's someone isn't what
you want them to be who you are new you
want to be dramatically taking your life
in a new direction can be terrifying but
having the faith in yourself to know
that you can figure it out
no matter what obstacle is present could
be all that you need often your goal is
get in the way of many missed
opportunities that could far exceed your
original plan so it's okay to not have a
plan or have specific goals sometimes
it's hard to see the bigger picture and
how you fit into that big picture and
that's okay too
you're still creating it and you always
will be
ten years ago I couldn't have told you
my plan on how to get here because this
here didn't even exist yet so one step
at a time I just focused on doing what
made me happy on what made me feel
challenged and excited and when I found
a community of people online who were
just as passionate creative and driven
as I was to create and make others happy
I knew I had found my home when I
started putting myself out there online
it felt like a chance to be not someone
I wasn't which i think is an accusation
we see play out online pretty often it
really felt like a chance to build up
those parts of myself that I wanted to
be stronger I wanted to feel more
confident when I often didn't I wanted
to connect with more people when I often
felt alone the first time reading a
comment from a stranger that I'd made
them laugh after having a rough day I
knew this was what I wanted to do
I saw the Internet as this new kind of
stage one that from an outside
perspective could be misconstrued but
from the inside looking out I could see
what it really was and it was you guys I
saw the friendships and the connections
being made in the comments at events
people finding the courage to be
themselves to be vulnerable
to be open to know that when you're met
with judgment that judgment has made you
stronger and that's not to say that the
judgment is fun the negativity online
and in life can be extremely hurtful and
at times it can drive you to a place
that you don't want to be a place where
you're presented with two choices
to be yourself or to be the way that
everyone wants you to be
but knowing those passing the judgment
on others are often fighting that same
confused battle as you are it can really
help put things back into perspective
bring the focus back to those who
support who care and want the best for
you so that you can do the same for them
that's where I feel truly lucky I've
always been stubborn in a good way I
never could give up the things that I
loved doing even when they left me
feeling isolated and alone I followed my
own interest and that alone led me to
this place I remember my first trip to
Los Angeles it was at this very spot
looking out of the ocean and the waves
when I first realized that anything is
possible I had no idea how but soon
after I would pick up and move here with
nothing more than my laptop and the
excitement of not knowing what's next
I just knew I'd figure it out
I'm still figuring it out and now I'm
back here at this very slot just
wondering what will be next
you
[Music]